I am breast cancer are lymphatic massages, okay. So this lymphatic massages I think are okay if you go to someone who's trained in cancer massage therapy.
I don't think just general lymphatic massages where they're going really deep and they could aggravate a cancer.
I don't think that's helpful. If they're gentle and they're staying away from the sight of the cancer, then I think you're fine, but you don't want to physically aggravate a cancer either.
So I'd be careful with that. I had a baby in September and was told not to do coffee animals. I am not pregnant now. So how often should I be doing coffee animals?
So we have some people that are doing coffee animals daily. We have some people that are really sick that are doing multiple coffee animals a day.
We have some people that are doing coffee animals once a week, a couple of times a week, and some people that are not doing coffee animals at all.
I fit into that category right now. I haven't had a coffee animal for a couple of months now.
So it really depends on how you're doing. If you're doing well and your cancer is in a relative state of revision, do you need to do coffee animals?
You've got to go look back at why you would do coffee animals. So number one, the number one reason why you do coffee animals in my book is to stimulate your parasympathetics.
So if you are a fairly herosympathetic driven person eating that you're really chill pill, you're really calm because your parasympathetics are going to calm your brain, they're going to calm your mind.
Let's say if you asked your best friend, probably not your husband, but if you asked your best friend, do you think I have a lot of anxiety and they were honest to you and said, yeah, you're kind of a high strong person, you're kind of a lot of anxiety that coffee animals are best for you.
If you're like, no, you are just so absolute chill, you're the chillest person I know.
If there be an honest then there's maybe a little bit less need for coffee animals, but it's not solely so the parasympathetics do other things.
So it stimulates your immune system, it stimulates your detoxification pathways. So if you have issues with your detoxification that pathways and coffee animals will help stimulate your detox pathways and your liver.
If you're having an increased growth of cancer and you need to hire stimulation of your immune system, coffee animals are the thing to do.
So not everybody needs to do coffee animals, don't listen to the step out there that if you don't are doing coffee animals, you're not going to get better from your cancer.
It's true, I have people maybe even on this call that have never done a coffee animal in their life and they're doing really well with their cancer.
So everybody is different.
Last part of this question I was told to do coffee animals can be dried to the body.
I would disagree with that.
I suggested to do seaweed animals to thoughts on this.
I would disagree with that seaweed animals seaweed is going to be a lot of iodine.
So remember what we've talked about with all the latest research on iodine and Hashimoto's so you have any issues with your thyroid and you're taking iodine for any length of time.
The high possibility that your any hypothyroidism is going to turn in Hashimoto's.
It will stimulate an auto immune attack on your thyroid, so not a big fan of seaweed animals for that reason.